what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and we have
not done this in a long time so for all
the people who are new to the channel
the purpose of the rumor roundup is to
cover all the news and rumors that you
may have missed over the course of the
week things that are cool that we may or
may not make videos on but it allows you
guys to get caught up because there's
just so much information out there
so the first thing we really have to do
to kick off this story or at least this
episode we got to talk about what it was
that jessica gau said now for those of
you guys who don't know jessica gao is
the producer behind the she-hulk show
and she had basically talked about where
it was that bruce banner's ship had gone
at the end of episode two now we all
kind of know what's going to zakar right
it's a secarian ship it's kind of hard
to believe that the sikarian ship is
going to the planet of the badoon be
kind of cool if it did but it's not
going to happen so we all know it's
going back to sakhar however when she
was asked this question jessica gao had
this to say well all i'll say is you
know he spent a lot of time off planet
as we saw in thor ragnarok and we only
got to see a little tiny bit of what his
life was like when he was on that planet
i mean god knows what hulk got up to in
the years that he was there so he's got
to go back and handle some off-world
things that happened during that time
now on the surface it seems pretty
straightforward the incredible hulk is
going back to zakar to handle some
off-world stuff however if we read
between the lines and we talk about the
fact this is going towards the planet
hulk world war hulk event most likely
what this seems to indicate or possibly
what we can allude to here is that
instead of the incredible hulk going
back to the planets of car and then
helping to get rid of the red king or
whoever is ruling the planet and
replacement of the grand master
following him being removed by the
different rebels that were there
we could say the incredible hulk already
had a family there after all when you're
the gladiatorial champion of a war-torn
world
it usually results in you getting laid
so it's not that far outside the realm
of possibility that the incredible hulk
was knocking some boots while he was on
sakaar and he maybe popped out a kit
this means that kaira could already
exist there it could mean that when he
gets there he actually has to deal with
his son because he didn't know he had
one there's all kinds of different
possibilities that go on but what it
does is it throws in this idea that
instead of the incredible hulk going
back to zakar to overthrow some king
instead the incredible hulk is going
back to zakar to basically learn that
he's got a family and then we'll see how
things unfold from there now i still say
that the events on sakhar however they
unfold will basically result in what's
essentially planet hulk and world war
hulk but i am curious to see how it
unfolds but the next story on our list
here disney plus confirms the release of
47 movies and shows that are coming to
the platform in september now most of
them we don't really care anything about
but the ones that we do care about and
there's really only three of them come
in this order september 8th we get thor
love and thunder and i got to tell you
guys i'm not surprised by the fact that
this movie was basically rushed to
disney plus
it wasn't that great it could have been
better right you know what is it that
that wonder woman meme it was good but
it could be better right i mean it's
entirely possible that you know the
movie was just
enjoyable by the general audience i'm
not shutting that notion down but as a
comic book fan and as somebody who
really enjoyed gore the god butcher i
didn't really care about the tentacles
on his head and the fact that he just
had a nose as opposed to not having a
nose right just i didn't really care
about the look what i cared about was
the character and the reality is they
just didn't really do the character
justice so it makes sense that given the
rating of the film given the general
response to the film that it's being
rushed to disney plus and they'll
probably try to recoup some measure of
their of their money there but the next
one that's coming out which you may or
may not care about is also on september
8th and that's obi-wan kenobi a jedi's
return now this is not a continuation of
the show in fact it's not really tied
into the show in any capacity outside of
the fact that it's just one of those
things that disney makes where they
basically do a behind-the-scenes making
of the show now on the surface it's easy
to dismiss that it's easy to look at
that and say like who wants to watch a
show about a show getting made right
like a show about shows but the truth
about this is whenever you watch those
behind the scenes making of a show they
actually dump information that we didn't
readily know about so in fact it may be
one of these things where the show comes
out and it actually gives us this kind
of teaser or tells us what direction
things may go in because it's a plot
point that they were saving for a later
date for example princess leia might
become relevant in the future of the of
the star wars universe before the events
of episode four she was kind of useful
in um oh my god rogue one that's what it
was i keep thinking rogue squadron every
time i think of rogue one i think of
rogue squadron probably because that
video game on the n64 was one of the
best video games ever but it was
actually better for the playstation if
he had a joystick and if he had the
naboo fighter do you guys remember the
naboo fighter from rogue squadron that
thing was op like it was ridiculously
overpowered i think maybe it was only
available for the for the pc although
maybe it wasn't maybe it was also
available for the n64 i don't remember
off top my head but that thing was a
monster it was ridiculously fast and
ridiculously overpowered but i digress
and maybe one of those things where just
kind of gives us plot points for the
future of where star wars may go
especially considering the relationship
between obi-wan kenobi and darth vader
but the final one that we're getting is
on september 21st and i'm really excited
about this because andor is the first
real star wars show that we're getting
that's not based on the skywalker saga
because i gotta be honest with you guys
i'm kind of tired of the skywalker saga
we've literally been getting that since
1999 and really if you want to go back
further since like the 70s and 80s but
the reality here is that i think that
what we could get with andor is just
world building and it looks like it's
going to be great i'm really excited for
it now one thing to be aware of all
three episodes at least the first three
episodes are releasing in the same day
so you get three hours of andor and then
we go into episode four the following
week now again there is a whole list
we'll have that list down in the in the
description so you guys can see
everything that's coming out uh but
moving on to our next topic matt reeves
and bruce tim's project the caped
crusader is looking for a new home
apparently and there are two viable
options here now one thing to understand
about batman the caped crusader is that
this is not a remake of batman the
animated series it's not really designed
to replace that although it does not
have pauldini attached to it and
pauldini and bruce tim were the ones who
initially launched batman the animated
series the matt reeves bruce tim project
is designed to be a reworking of the
batman mythos in animated form now most
likely because matt reeves is part of
the project it's going to basically
build the kind of robert pattinson
batman world that they are presumably
familiar with but the truth is with
discovery going through after their
acquisition of warner brothers and just
taking a just hatchet to everything
right just axing everything that the
cave crusader seems to be a part of that
now unlike batgirl which was just
outright cancelled and is not going to
be released in any capacity it seems
that warner brothers in discovery are
fine with somebody else working on the
project and they're basically being
removed financially from their hands so
at the moment it's being shopped around
again netflix and disney are the two top
people that are in talks to get a hold
of it i'm not gonna lie it seem a little
strange to see like a batman project on
disney which is the home of marvel but
at the same time whoever gets their
hands on it it's gonna be the smart move
it's a smart move for netflix because
their entire streaming service is just a
laboring beast gasping for breath as
evidenced by the fact that they're just
canceling everything literally they're
cutting down they're doing the tv show
equivalent of a company basically laying
everybody off or at least reducing their
workforce by a huge percentage that's
basically what netflix is doing it's
smart for disney because they'll just
continue to make money hand over fist
but whoever it ends up going to i'm
excited for it this might be one of
those very rare instances where netflix
gets it i fire my netflix subscription
up for like a month watch it and then
cancel it again right you know how
everybody used to do with wwe network
back in the day whenever wrestlemania
came on but moving away from movies and
tv shows and stuff as we normally used
to do here on the room of roundup and as
we'll continue to do here on the room
around up let's transition over to
gaming specifically because of the fact
that gamescom has wrapped up now for
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with gamescom it's a giant
gaming convention and really i would say
after the cancellation of e3 it's kind
of the new e3 right the big gaming
convention where everybody shows up and
they all talk about their projects and
different things like that now depending
on who you talk to some people will say
that gamescom was a snooze fest this
year and the reality is that when it
comes to things like gamescom that one's
probably also going to die off too the
reason for that being the same reason
that e3 died off why would everybody
show up to a convention and then compete
for the audience you know xbox
playstation all that kind of stuff when
they could all just host their own
events and probably do it cheaper than
they can having to like show up to e3
set up a great huge booth different
things like that they already own
studios they're already on the space why
not just do it in-house it's always more
affordable to do things in-house than it
is to basically go outside of your home
and hire people to do things for you and
so regarding the different projects that
we saw one of the things that we got
here was sonic frontiers now for those
of you guys who are familiar with that
sonic frontiers is basically a sonic
open world game now as much excitement
as there was about sonic frontiers there
was also a little bit of controversy so
one of the things we got was like new
cut scenes we got some new mechanics
that allowed you to see how sonic could
maneuver in this new open world game but
we also got something called cyber space
levels which is basically just a remix
of previous levels from previous sonic
games and the truth about this is a lot
of sonic fans just blasted sega on
twitter calling them lazy and just
saying like it's a really lazy thing
instead of developing new content
they're literally just reworking old
content and in truth i can see where
fans are coming from the one other thing
video game fans do not want is for the
video games industry to become hollywood
where instead of producing new things
they just remake and rework old stuff
and in truth that's kind of what we're
seeing around the video game franchises
we're seeing situations where video game
companies are just remaking old games
instead of creating new games that's why
a lot of people are turning to the indie
game landscape to just find new and
interesting things because for aaa
titles either it's a game as a service
where they're just nickel and diming you
for everything or it's just rehashes and
remakes and reworks and read whatever of
all the stuff you've already seen the
other part of this is that while the
game itself was billed as this just
massive project where players could just
play you know seemingly endlessly that
within the timed gameplay the timed demo
that somebody was playing at gamescom
they actually beat the first level
when they weren't supposed to
they beat it faster than expected now a
lot of that's also because they're super
hardcore sonic fans and they're really
really good at being able to like time
speed or speed run through those
individual levels but the other part of
this is that there was apparently a
glitch that was revealed during this
time and sega banned anybody from being
able to record anything else at gamescom
now in truth that's not uncommon it
happens sometimes sometimes it's due to
something egregious for example when
assassin's creed black flag was demoted
e3 the game wasn't ready but sony
basically forced the demo anyway and the
game crashed at least i'm pretty sure it
was assassin's creed black flag so it's
not that uncommon to see this kind of a
thing unfold where sometimes bugs popped
up different things like that i mean at
this point in the the video game
landscape we're used to games being
shipped in a semi-broken state and then
being nickel and dimed to get the
completed version of the game whether
it's a business decision or it's just
poor development it's really up to how
you interpret it but sometimes these
things happen so i'm not really too bit
out of shape over that but following
that we got the dune awakening trailer
which is a video game based in the dune
universe honestly i'm really excited
about this i would by no means say that
i'm an expert when it comes to the dune
mythos i'm really not i've seen the
original movie i saw the new movie with
dennis villeneuve at least part one and
that's about as far as my knowledge goes
right house of tradies the spice must
flow a couple memes here and there but
that's basically it looking at the video
game it looks phenomenal now whether or
not it'll be phenomenal we'll simply
have to wait until it comes out right i
mean overkill's the walking dead looked
amazing when it came out it was a
dumpster fire but having said that i'm
really hoping this game looks or at
least plays as good as it looks and i've
got faith in it i believe this game is
going to be a good game regardless all
we really got was a trailer reveal and
just this revelation or at least we've
kind of known for a little while that
it's just a giant mmo game but i'm
excited for it of course if you guys are
interested beta sign ups are currently
open now the other thing we got here is
that on february 3rd in 2023 we're
finally going to get dead island 2. and
i got to tell you guys i get that dead
island had just a series of issues when
that game came out it was it was glitchy
it was buggy right it had some major
problems and they fixed it i loved dead
island and one of the things i loved the
most about the dead island game was the
drop-in dropout mechanic so those of you
guys who don't know what that was
literally anybody who was on your
friend's list and had dead island could
just jump into your game wherever you
happen to be now there were certain jump
in you know drop in drop out points it
couldn't just be arbitrary you kind of
had to go to a point where they'd be
able to jump in and jump out but like
they could just join you and it was
great i loved dead island i had an
absolute blast playing that game sure it
had problems but those problems were
easily rectified dead island 2 really
struggled and went through development
hell and we might make a video talking
about that as we get closer to the
release date of the video game but i'm
excited right i think that'd make a
great editorial video to be honest with
you guys but i'm excited for it i'm
really really really looking forward to
it and honestly
i might just kind of send out some
invites and just say hey does anybody
want to play dead island 2 with me we
can just goof around kill some bosses
fight some some zombies and just kind of
call it a day
now later on in february actually on
february 28th in 2023 the lightfall
expansion for destiny 2 is going to be
coming out now here's the funny thing i
lived and died by destiny right i played
the first destiny game and i i lived on
that game right i was god i was
ridiculously good at crucible in that
game i kind of miss having that 7.7 kd
like i think it was like 7.2 kd i was
nuts in crucible on destiny 1. just
ridiculous but a lot of that was because
i was coming out of uh call of duty and
while destiny was not really a twitch
shooter in terms of crucible it wasn't
really that far removed it would felt
more like halo than anything else so i
was able to navigate myself pretty well
but i did love the first destiny game
destiny 2 i played the hell out of that
game i actually dropped off before the
new expansion came out and i don't even
remember what the new expansion is
called but i dropped off before that
expansion came out the funny thing about
it is a lot of people once i got back on
and i got back on maybe like a week ago
a lot of people were talking about how
the new expansion feels a lot like the
taken king from destiny 1. it's like
this wholesale reworking they're
introducing all kinds of new mechanics
and the game is as enjoyable as it's
been in years or at least more enjoyable
than it's been in years like people love
it now now again how long that's going
to last i'm not entirely sure but i am
getting back into it so i am excited for
the the lightfall expansion one of the
big complaints that i've heard about
destiny recently is that unless you buy
the expansion they charge you for like
each individual raid they charge you for
each individual dungeon they nickel and
dime the hell out of you and i can
certainly see how that's driving casual
players away because it's one thing for
people to say okay look it's fair if
like i get the expansions and stuff or i
get the dungeons and so on maybe like a
month later right because the people who
are paying for it get it right now but
to say that like you'll never get it
unless you pay for it that pisses people
off right there is such a thing as
nickel and diming people to the point
where you actually alienate them from
your product and i think that's one of
the issues or at least i understand that
to be one of the issues that destiny 2
is being plagued with but at the end of
the day
gaming is no longer about creating games
that people enjoy it's about creating
games that people keep paying for and so
it's just kind of the situation that
we're in the alternative is to just stop
buying aaa games and focusing on indie
games which in all honesty i think
that's going to become a massive shift
here in about the next five years or so
but following that and actually kind of
taking a step back and moving into this
year right which is october 21st and
2022 we are getting new tales from the
borderlands and the reality about this
is
i'm a little on the fence i don't want
to i don't want to be like a negative
nancy this episode i really hope i'm not
coming off that way it's gonna be a
telltale style game now it's not gonna
be produced by telltale games they're
defunct right they they went belly up
like three years ago i think they were
acquired recently but telltale games as
we knew them right when they made the
walking dead they're gone right but it's
gonna be a game that's gonna feel like a
telltale's game if i'm being honest with
you guys i feel like borderlands peaked
with borderlands 2 and just never quite
recovered it just never really seemed to
reach its level of popularity now i
think a lot of that's because
borderlands 2 came out at that point in
time when it was just sort of the golden
age of gaming for like modern gamers so
when you look at things like uh what is
it like bioshock infinite things like
that like all those games kind of seem
to come out around the same time and so
it was a really great time to be a gamer
but in reality i mean i want to play it
you know i want to see what it's like
i'm not going to write it off and just
call it like a really crappy game but i
am excited to see what this game looks
like but having said that for all you
guys out there who are andrew garfield
fans right transitioning back into
movies those guys out there who are
andrew garfield fans this is our final
story here right this is us wrapping up
this episode with really kind of a big
revelation so at the time we're
recording this video this week this
coming thursday slash friday that we get
spider-man no way home released back
into theaters but it's gonna have bonus
footage footage that was not there
in the first film now this may or may
not be a spoiler to you so just be aware
going forward there is apparently a
scene in that movie when andrew garfield
makes the offhand remark and saying we
should team up again and the response of
toby maguire is we definitely will and
so what this has done is it's basically
led people to believe that andrew
garfield is going to return to the
marvel cinematic universe spider-man
landscape not the sony landscape he
might get his own sony film i don't
really know i mean that's one of those
things that's kind of rumored and i
don't think we definitively know for
sure we know our projects in the works
but how far reaching is going to be i
don't think we definitively know not
until anything is officially announced
by sony and we likely get a trailer but
the thing about this is having andrew
garfield return to the spider-man marvel
cinematic universe landscape really begs
the question what form is that going to
take if i'm a betting man i would bet
all the money in my pockets to all the
money in your pockets that we're still
going to get this giant spider-verse
type event we already have it being
built up right like into the spider
verse into the spider verse beyond
spider verse like different things like
that like we're already getting that
right we're already getting this kind of
build up of the different spider
characters throughout the multiverse
whether it's small little cameos or
major roles like what we saw with miles
and spiderman noir and spider-ham and
spider-gwen but regardless i could
definitely see them building up to just
some giant spider-verse-centric event
and the rumors are that they are and so
it'd be interesting albeit a little bit
strange to see andrew garfield and toby
maguire and tom holland teaming up as
their real life counterparts with like
animated miles morales and animated
miguel o'hara who we'll see in the new
spider-verse film and like spider-ham
and spider-man noir and spider-gwen all
of whom are animated potentially with
other live-action versions of spider-man
that we simply haven't seen yet it'll be
a cool thing and i'm excited to see what
that looks like there's a lot of stuff
that they can do there because one of
the things to know is that what they did
with regards to spider-man no way home
and andrew garfield and toby mcguire
returning to their own universes it's
exactly what happened at the end of
spider-verse right the original dr
octopus superior spider-man story for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with that let's turn our heads to comic
books for a second and let's talk about
how this unfolded so spider-verse was
actually a giant comic book event that
took place between two issues of
superior spider-man when dr octopus got
the body of peter parker but when that
story ended like you literally read
superior spider-man by itself he ends up
disappearing due to some like some
massive energy-based explosion at
horizon labs and then just reappears at
the end of that issue and then just
talks about how crazy everything was you
don't know what actually happened if you
only read superior spider-man but if you
go and you read spider-verse you end up
finding out he was thrown into the
multiverse and in his efforts to get
back to his to the main marvel universe
he ended up coming across these
alternate realities and realizing that
the different spider-man of these
alternate realities we're being killed
by somebody and that leads into the
spider-verse event now that with the
inheritors and all that kind of stuff a
guy named karn and so on and so forth
and
god solace was a really cool villain i
don't care what anybody says but the
important thing about this is that it
was basically a story that took place
within a particular like just within a
larger story arc itself and you wouldn't
know unless you read that particular
story you could easily do that with with
like andrew garfield or toby mcguire you
could have a whole series of films play
out where literally before andrew
garfield got back to his own universe
all this stuff happened right he was
thrilled like he was literally sent back
to his own universe by doctor strange or
whatever it was but ended up being
thrown into the multiverse due to the
multiverse coming back in the events of
loki and it threw him off course and he
ended up in an alternate reality and
that he was literally bouncing from one
alternate reality to the other trying to
get back to his own and along the way
that's how you're introduced to all
these live-action versions of spider-man
you can do the same thing with toby
mcguire so you're kind of doubling up
right so you get like spider punk or you
get like all these different versions of
peter parker some of whom are evil some
of whom are good guys right you get the
same thing with toby mcguire he does the
exact same thing so literally over the
course of this film you build up the
spider-man mythos so that when you have
this great big huge spider-verse event
suddenly you get the return of this
particular spider-man that you saw in
andrew garfield's spider-man film who
only showed up for about five minutes 20
minutes into the movie it's one of those
cool things that they could do whether
they will or not i have no idea but the
fact remains here that that's kind of
the big thing or at least one of the big
things you're gonna see and if that's a
reveal that we get in the new spider-man
no way home film i'm excited to see what
else we get it's not going to be like an
extra hour's worth of footage right it's
literally like they're literally
re-releasing this as a cash grab because
they know it's going to make money and
it will
because we're going to go back and see
it we want to relive those moments right
those those nostalgic moments we were
all watching the first film and they
team up right you know peter won peter
two peter three like we wanna see all
that stuff right we just wanna relive
all those moments and i think it'll be a
blast i'm really excited to do that
again but with that being said guys this
can this this consumes this consumes
this concludes
our inaugural return episode of the
rumor roundup with our new set got a
little bit of greenery because some of
you guys said that i needed a plant here
i'm going to replace this with a sign
that's what i'm going to do and i think
i might change the messaging on the sign
from time to time i think it'd be kind
of funny but anyway guys thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace